one of the two men suspected of mass
murder in canada has been found dead
near the scene of the crimes in a remote
indigenous community
damien sanderson aged 31 had been sought
along with his brother 30 year old miles
sanderson in the stabbing deaths of 10
people in the james smith cree reserve
in saskatchewan the deceased is damien
sanderson
his body was located outdoors in a
heavily grassed area in proximity to a
house that was being examined
we can confirm he has visible injuries
these injuries are not believed to be
self-inflicted at this point asked
whether damien sanderson's brother miles
killed him police said they couldn't be
sure they think miles was spotted in the
provincial capital regina on sunday
miles has a lengthy criminal record
involving both persons and property
crimes the sprawling manhunt now
stretches across canada's three vast
prairie provinces of saskatchewan
alberta and manitoba in addition to the
10 people stabbed to death 18 people
were injured the motive in the brutal
attacks remains unknown police say
canadian prime minister justin trudeau
promised additional resources for the
stricken community this kind of violence
or any kind of violence
has no place in our country
we're still of course monitoring the
situation closely and we urge everyone
to follow all the updates from the
authorities
priority is keeping you and your loved
ones safe so please be careful
the saskatchewan killings are one of the
worst mass murders in canadian history
rob reynolds al jazeera